[موسيقى]
بعيدًا عن شهرة المدينة الصاخبة
تظهر من الرمال مثل موطن السراب
لما أسماه الفراعنة
بلد البحيرة الذي
ينتجه من هذا الحوض الخصب الذي
غذى وغذى مصر
لآلاف السنين اليوم هذا
المشهد القديم يشكل بعضًا من
أحدث
فن الطهي في مصر  الاتجاهات كان عمري حوالي 14 عامًا
في المرة الأولى التي أتيت فيها
مع والدي ، الدهشة التي أشعر بها
أنني لم أر بحيرة في مصر قبل
أن تتقدم في العمر أبدًا
، أصبح أحمد المفتي يركز على الشهرة في
نهاية المطاف ، وترك مهنة استمرت عقدًا من الزمان
في  إدارة مستشفى لهذا
العقار الذي تبلغ مساحته 45 فدانًا مع مطعم مزرعة
وفندق يسمى komaldika ، إنه واحد من
أولى منتجعات السياحة الزراعية في مصر
مع سمعة سريعة النمو لبعض
المنتجات والمأكولات الطازجة في المنطقة ، حيث
يتم حصاد ثمانين بالمائة من الطعام هنا
الموقع ، فإن
مفهوم شوكة المزرعة هو حقًا مفهوم بسيط للغاية
إلى حد كبير يعود إلى جذور الطريقة
التي اعتدنا على تناول الطعام بها دائمًا ، وستستمتع حقًا
بالمنتج الذي ينتجه  كانت essence
komaldika في الأصل مزرعة زيتون
منذ ثلاثة عقود
، وليس من قبيل المصادفة أنها بالقرب من
بحيرة كارون
في عصور ما قبل التاريخ ، تم تحويل المياه
هنا من النيل
مما جعل الشهرة واحدة من الأماكن الأولى في
شمال مصر لممارسة الزراعة
وهي العادة التي يفخر أحمد بمواصلتها
هذا ما نحرص
عليه حقًا هو عدم تغيير أي شيء
حقًا ، فنحن في الحقيقة نقوم فقط
بتسخير جمال المكان الذي يعد هذا
النظام البيئي الخصب أيضًا موطنًا لأكثر من 80
نوعًا من الطيور
وهذا هو سبب تطور أطباق الحمام والبط
إلى تخصصات
إقليمية تتماشى مع  هذا التقليد أحمد يربي
الدواجن من أجل
الوجبة المميزة لمطعمه ، طبق البط في أبسط صوره
وهذا
هو جزء من الجمال إنه الطعم
نفسه ، يتم غلي البط مع حفنة
من البهارات والخضروات لأكثر من ساعة
ثم يتم تحميصها بسرعة مثل كل
جانب من جوانب كومالديكا ،
فإن الطبق يضفي نكهات الشهرة النقية ،
والتفاني في البساطة المستمدة من
رحلة أحمد الأولى هنا مع
والده.
أنا komede kadika هو الاسم العربي
للمقعد ، الفكرة تتعلق حقًا
بوالدي ، كان حلمه الأكبر
هو القدوم إلى الفيوم والجلوس على
المقعد والاستمتاع بالهدوء الذي دائمًا ما يلهمني